bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7-8
politique dans cette édition du 17 juin
deux invités jean philippe mallet le
député socialiste des yvelines qui me
rejoindre à tout à l'heure pour évoquer
l appel des sens il fait partie de ce
groupe que certains qualifient de
rebelles au sein de la majorité mais
pour débuter j'accueille antoine des
bons soirs soit le président de la
fédération des jeunes udi des yvelines
les jeunes udi qui viennent de tenir
avec leurs aînés d'ailleurs le premier
congrès national ce week end votre
section un peu plus d'un an deux
campagnes électorales viennent d'être
mené municipales européennes l'heure est
au bilan et quel bilan justement vous
faites de cette très longue année
politique alors un bilan global c'est
quand même compliqué avant tout preuve
d'un coup mais globalement c'est la jsk
ça s'est bien passé oui tout s'est bien
passé les municipales se sont bien
passés les européennes mieux qu'on
pouvait l'espérer donc de ce point de
vue là où on n'a aucun souci puis après
de toutes les activités plus locale et
donc départementale ça s'est très bien
passé aussi avec une très belle
dynamique donc aucun problème vous avez
le sentiment d'avoir développé une
stratégie payante parce que lors des
municipales il y avait des alliances qui
n'était pas forcément être très clair
pour les électeurs soit avec l'ump soit
avec le modem c'était en fonction des
devil en revanche c'était forcément plus
nette pour les européennes avec
l'alternative le modem uniquement
c'était le bon choix vous n'avez pas
perdu des électeurs avec au début la
mise en route plutôt difficile sur la
recherche d'alliés de partenaires c'est
toujours compliqué quelle que soit la
stratégie on en perd et on en gagne
l'important c'est la voisine clair on
était les seuls à van ninh claira limite
peut être aussi le fn à l'opposé
d'ailleurs je crois sincèrement que sa
nouvelle aujourd'hui polarisation de la
vie politique on a les libéraux pro
européens
d'un côté on a les conservateurs
nationaliste d'autres essais cet hiver
claire qui paye aujourd'hui donc après
qu'est ce qu'on en a perdu peut-être
parce qu'on n'était pas assez
conservateur ou au contraire parce que
on convenait pas tout à fait à ce qu'on
avait jusqu'à aujourd'hui au centre
c'est à dire un parti clair là on l'a
donc je pense qu'au contraire on en a
plutôt gagné en tout cas en terme de
qualification c'est clair aujourd'hui
vous dit
bi polarisation de la politique mais udi
front national oui c'est on le voit très
bien élevés n'existe plus bas donnez-moi
de son panel a disparu mais moi
typiquement leur ligne politique sur les
questions économiques monique moreau
peine on a parlé beaucoup de zéros plein
pour la campagne mais pas uniquement
même sur les questions sociales
sociétales économiques environnementales
écologistes toutes ces questions là ils
n'ont pas de réponse claire vous prenez
en bruno le maire d'un côté ou d'un
mariani de l'autre à droite vous pouvez
prendre un manuel valls ou un gérard
filoche à gauche c'est la même chose
c'est complètement explosé il n'y a pas
d'idéologie dans ces parties aujourd'hui
donc lui d y est un parti qui se suffit
à lui-même plus d'alliance plus de
rapprochement comment vous voyez
l'avenir l'évolution du parti on reste
dans le giron de l'ump on s'en éloigne
alors non et d'ailleurs le congrès
national de ce week-end a permis de
clairement clarifier les choses
aujourd'hui on réaffirme le hideux lui
dit c'est à dire que nous sommes un
parti indépendant c'est absolument
primordiale indépendant du centre de
partis centristes à dire le modèle
indépendant de la droite de l'ump nous
avons notre corpus idéologique on
s'appuie là-dessus nous avons nos
militants nous avons une structure
maintenant donc nous sommes
indépendamment nous sommes indépendants
structurellement et intellectuellement
il n'y aura pas de fusion avec le modem
on verra quelle forme ça ça aura
aujourd'hui nous responsables politiques
au niveau national n'ont aucune envie de
couper tous les ponts qui ont été
construits pendant la campagne des
européennes seraient d'ailleurs aucun
sens par contre il faut savoir après
dans les mois qui viennent quelle forme
ça va prendre est-ce qu'on va continuer
à avoir des actions locales sur le
terrain ensemble est-ce que ça va le
prendre la forme de congrès ce que ça va
prendre la forme de réunions publiques
ça on ne sait pas encore savoir et vous
souhaitez quoi justement pour l'avenir
de lui dit qu'est ce qui serait plus
clair pour vous mal plus clair moi ce
que je souhaite comme beaucoup des
militants centristes c'est une fusion à
long terme en tout cas en regroupement
progressivement de nous de nos chapelles
avec une seule est belle entité c'est
comme ça que nous avons été efficaces
pour les européennes c'est comme ça
qu'on sera efficace sur le long terme
politiquement parce que c'est ce
qu'attendent les citoyens ils savent
plus quoi voter le centre c'était déjà
un peu le foutoir pour ne parler
clairement et encore peu de temps depuis
un an avec lui dit le modem nous avons
beau party qui fonctionne plutôt bien
donc ça serait dommage de rester
uniquement là dessus pas continuer le
chemin qui a été construit jusqu'à
maintenant sans risque de voir ensuite
une fois les deux formations vraiment
rapprocher voire fusionner de nouvelles
tensions apparaître avec des tendances
différentes comme ça et on à l'ump des
socialistes est ce que c'est pas le
risque de voir avec une seule et même
formation udi qui regrouperait tous le
centre des nouvelles tendances c'est
toujours le risque mais en même temps
enfin service que cela existait déjà ces
derniers mois ça nous a pas empêchés de
travailler ensemble sur des lignes assez
précises puisque nous avions les mêmes
projets au niveau européen je reviens à
chaque fois sur le projet européen mais
c'est ce qui nous a réunis ce coup ci
donc après évidemment si on doit
travailler ensemble c'est aux deux
parties de clarifier leurs lignes lui
dit a toujours été extrêmement clairs
typiquement après c'est aussi au modem à
savoir monsieur bayrou de savoir sur
quelle ligne ils veulent travailler
demain congrès en novembre pour désigner
le nouveau président de l'udps et après
la démission de jean louis borloo pour
l'heure il n'y a qu'un seul candidat
député maire de neuilly jean-christophe
fromantin il s'est déclaré
officiellement c'est l'homme de la
situation vous attendez d'autres
candidatures il y aura certainement
d'autres c'est pas une surprise donc moi
j'attends de voir enfin par exemple
hervé morin jean christophe lagarde ça a
priori les deux candidats qu'on attend
le plus en parallèle il n'y aura
peut-être d'autres on peut on ne sait
pas il y aura peut-être jean arthuis
peut-être chantal jouanno ne sais pas je
mais vous n'avez pas de candidat moi
personnellement non à titre personnel
non vous attendez de voir comment ça va
se passer vous mettez en retrait vous
n'allez pas vous impliquer dans cette
campagne interne je m'appliquerai dans
le sens où je viendrai accueillir les
candidats qui viendront dans les
yvelines je m'impliquerai dans le sens
où je suis militant comme les autres et
donc je viendrai aux réunions publiques
il ce qui ce qui se monteront par contre
en temps créé ce concept départemental
je n'ai pas envie de m'impliquer
aujourd'hui au nom précisément d'une
chapelle au risque de diviser militants
lui d iron var précise et un tel
recrutement aussi de plusieurs
formations plusieurs tendancielle parti
radical qui tient une place importante
et au parti radical actuellement il ya
déjà cette élection interne pour
succéder là aussi à jean louis borloo le
maire de nancy laurent hénart ou encore
l'ex ministre rama yade qui se livrent
une bataille plutôt rude sur fond d'
adhésion d'un flot d'adhésion à ces
assez suspecte on verra les évolutions
les différentes enquêtes qui sont menées
mon interne quel regard vous portez sur
la situation au parti radical et ces
tensions vraiment de plus en plus forte
oui je crois qu'elles sont quand même un
petit peu aplani ces derniers jours il
ya eu la semaine dernière effectivement
des articles notamment dans les prés
s'écrit déclarations des deux candidats
aussi entre eux ils assurent bien sûr
non mais les tensions sont réels je vais
pas m'amuser à cacher est ce que tout le
monde voit ça n'a pas de sens par contre
il faut quand même un petit peu minimisé
après des comptes qui aurait certaines
seulement une centaine d'adhésions deux
cas un peu litigieux bon une centaine
sur plusieurs milliers c'est quand même
relativement modeste sachant également
que uniquement pourront participer au
vote ce qui se sont à des ceux qui ont
adhéré ou réadhérer avant le 16 mai donc
toutes les adhésions de dernière minute
ce qu'elles soient de bonne foi ou pas
de toute façon ne seront pas prises en
compte et encore une fois tous les
candidats on peut avoir accès au fichier
donc voilà c'est lé tout les touts les
tiraillements peu stérile je pense que
c'est pas la peine nécessairement de
mettre la lumière davantage dessus c'est
en tout cas deux visions qui se dégage
pour l'avenir du parti radical se sont
pas forcément les mêmes personnes qui
vont incarner le parti que ce soit rama
yade ou laurent hénart vous avez là
aussi un regard où vous mettez en
retrait oh c'est pas une question de
retrait je ne suis pas militant du parti
radical mais c'est une composante
importante bien sûr bien sûr mais j'ai
pas mon mot à dire en tant que président
la fédération des jeunes munis des
yvelines et puis encore une fois moi je
suis là pour parler représenté lui dit
il parti radical je laisse cela aux
militants du parti radical si j'avais
été militant du parti radical peut-être
que je vous auriez dit un mot mais la
franchise strauss kahn ne peut pas nuire
à lui dit aussi je pense pas faut aussi
milliards de succession après jean louis
borloo qui va s'ouvrir aussi forcément
j'appellerais passer à une guerre c'est
dans tout parti doit avoir une
démocratie interne alors évidemment dès
qu'il ya démocratie ça nécessite une
certaine concurrence et donc parfois un
peu de hoerdt mais en dehors de ça c'est
naturel donc je ne pense pas qu'il
faille davantage mettre en lumière
encore une fois ce genre de petits des
petits des bains pour revenir vraiment
aux jeunes du délit en france dans les
yvelines aussi en terme d'adhérents ça
représente quoi aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est difficile à dire on
est
on va dire une un bon millier
au dernier congrès de ce week end nous
étions 200 à paris de toute la france
est remontée donc une belle dynamique
encore une fois qui continue et comment
va se passer la rentrée l'année 2015 il
y aura forcément moins d'élections en
tout cas sur notre secteur sur les
yvelines sur l'île de france ce qu'il y
aura les sénatoriales mais ça ne
concernera pas le renouvellement des
sénateurs en place sur notre département
sur notre région pour vous les objectifs
sur 2015 c'est quoi que la campagne déjà
interne se passe bien pour la céder
l'idée c'est évident et au delà de ça
pour lors de la campagne et en dehors de
ça continue sur le terrain c'est ce qui
a payé pendant tous ces mois nous étions
quasiment le seul parti à être présents
non stop auprès des citoyens a expliqué
à nous montrer et pas toujours un tract
à la main aussi simplement échanger
écouter écouter l'envi les besoins des
citoyens pour suivre sa à travers de
nouveaux outils parce que la politique
et les français attendent de nouveaux
outils aussi de politiques comme ça ça
va se poursuivre ça va se poursuivre le
terrain parce que souvent les formations
politiques on les voit avant les
élections sur juste avant c'est
évidemment évidemment mais au contraire
nous notre but c'est on va dire une
formule assez ordinaire mais c'est
concret on l'a fait depuis un an on va
le poursuivre c'est faire de la
politique autrement encore une fois
c'est faire du terrain est rallié
l'arrivée au sein des conseils
municipaux au gré des alliances aussi
avec d'autres formats sur rue dans le
département ump ou au modem ou autre et
vous êtes arrivé aux affaires en tout
cas avec des postes de maires adjoints
la hausse il va falloir faire vos
preuves évidemment mais c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est pas uniquement être le
porte drapeau c'est la force de l'ue dit
certes une plus petite structure qu'on
peut avoir par exemple à l'ump ou au ps
mais ça permet aussi aux militants qui
on envie et qui s'impliquent au sein du
mouvement de pouvoir évoluer être
contacter évidemment d'une part auprès
des citoyens mais aussi de l'autre de
nos élus locaux et ça effectivement ça
nous permet d'être manette très
rapidement est 2e au delà des mots être
aux manettes et savoir ce que faisait
qu'exercer un monde a même local aura
l'occasion de refaire un bilan une fois
que les premiers mois seront passés
merci à merci à vous rappelle que vous
êtes le responsable des jeunes udi des
yvelines formation qui a un peu plus
d'un an maintenant merci merci dans un
instant c'est à jean philippe mallet le
député socialiste des yvelines qui va
prendre votre place tout d'abord je vous
propose d'écouter
lefrançois de ligne et le maire de
guyancourt il est conseiller général des
yvelines socialiste il siège dans
l'opposition à saint quentin en yvelines
il nous a expliqué sa vision du
développement de cette intercommunalité
contrairement à la nouvelle équipe en
place il ne préconise pas un
rapprochement avec des communes comme
maurepas plaisir ou encore lé
clayes-sous-bois mais plutôt avec elle
au yen l'opération d'intérêt national de
saclay c'est au micro de catherine
château question c'est pas de savoir
est-ce qu'on accole telle ou telle
commune jusqu'à présent isolées ou en
intercommunautés provisoire la vraie
question c'est comment ce territoire
doit évoluer et avec quel projet
qu'est-ce qu'on aura comme projet en
commun pour porter ensemble ce qu'on
appelle un projet de territoire
justement mais moi je crois que c'est
les questions de développement
économique de développement
universitaire et de recherche est
également de transport structurants ces
questions qu'on retrouve au sein de
l'opération d'intérêt national qui doit
être déterminante est donc pour lui en
cours et pour d'autres communes aussi de
saint quentin en yvelines il est
important de se tourner vers ses projets
d'avenir plutôt que de simplement faire
des calculs d'addition de communes
isolées je rappelle que l'opération
d'intérêt national c'est sur le
territoire de saclay nous sommes la
partie occidentale du plateau de saclay
il faut se tourner aussi vers nos
voisins il ya versailles grand parc ya
la caps et c'est avec eux qu'il faut
regarder quelques opérations et quel
avenir sur des sujets d'importance jean
philippe mallet bonsoir vous êtes député
des yvelines socialiste on vient
d'entendre françois de ligne et votre
collègue au conseil général des yvelines
puisque vous êtes également vous siégez
également au département il évoquait le
développement de l'agglomération de
saint quentin maintenant qu'il est dans
l'opposition après avoir connu est la
majorité sur les précédentes mandatures
est-ce que vous partager sa vision
saint-quentin doit davantage échanger
avec le yen plutôt que de se rallier à
d'autres communes comme leur part à
plaisir les clés très certainement il se
le discours que nous avons porté
également avec françois de ligne auprès
de monsieur le préfet
la cohérence la rationalité les moyens
qui seront données par l'état c'est
celle au yen donc mettons à profit cette
plus value des moyens donnés par l'état
qui va mettre de l'argent dans cette
opération d'intérêt national
pour pour travailler avec avec le
plateau de saclay qui va connaître un
développement important
plutôt que de faire des alliances
dépendant de personnes du bon vouloir de
certains élus privilégions la cohérence
et l'efficacité de cette opération
d'intérêt national qui d'ailleurs a été
créée sous l'ancienne majorité
présidentielle qui ne ressort pas d'une
logique politique mais bien d'une
logique économique et de déjà je le
disais vous êtes député conseiller
général cette semaine c'est valérie
pécresse responsables de l'ump et dans
les yvelines ancienne ministre et qui
disait à propos de la réforme
territoriale de françois hollande est
que c'était un rendez vous manqué elle
veut la suppression rapide des
départements pour de réelles économies
notamment parce que vous êtes d'accord
il faut supprimer les départements
écouter
demain d'ailleurs pardon c'est demain
que la réforme territoriale de madrid
voilà les deux textes qui vont porter
les deux textes de lois qui vont porter
la réforme territoriale seront sur la
table dieu du conseil des ministres
la réforme territoriale c'est beaucoup
de choses mais en particulier la
suppression des conseils départementaux
pas des départements des conseils
généraux conseils départementaux à
horizon 2020 il va y arriver il est vrai
que ça aille plus vite faudra lui faire
dès maintenant pour faire des vraies
économies oui mais écoutez on eu
beaucoup de personnalité je pense à un
démographe un anthropologue comme hervé
le bras
des intellectuels des des gens qui
réfléchissent un petit peu à ce qu'est
la france son histoire sa géographie met
en garde également le gouvernement
disant mais on ne supprime pas d'un
trait de plume comme ça une collectivité
qui a été il ya déjà deux cents ans
d'âge créé par la révolution française
qui est dans l'imaginaire collectif des
français donc les choses se font avec un
minimum de temps et de et de précaution
voilà donc la réforme est bonne hein
forme territoriale telle qu'elle est
présentée pour l'instant vous revient
elle nous convient dans ses grandes
lignes mais là aussi j'attends
j'attendrai avec avec impatience et
beaucoup d'intérêt la discussion
parlementaire qui va commencer au
sérieux au mois deux mois de juillet
avant d'aller à l'assemblée nationale en
septembre et octobre j'imagine et ce qui
nous amène forcément à l'objet principal
de votre venue ce soir vous faites
partie de ces députés socialistes à
soutenir l'appel des sens et ce
collectif qui souhaitent plus d'emplois
plus de justice sociale de la part du
gouvernement est ce que vous vous
considérez comme un rebelle face au
gouvernement c'est le cas lié c'est la
qualification qui est utilisée parfois
par certains oui pas du tout pas du tout
par mail ni rebelle ni frondeurs
simplement quelqu'un qui un élu un
député un citoyen engagé et qui entend
être être cohérent justement avec ses
engagements
s'il s'agit de comment dire d'assainir
les comptes publics d'être dans le
sérieux budgétaire moi j'y suis tout à
fait favorable vous savez que depuis
1974 l'état n'a pas voté un budget en
équilibre et on voit bien à quel que
niveau quel niveau atteint la dette
aujourd'hui donc effectivement il faut
faire il faut faire des efforts pour se
donner des marges de manoeuvre il faut
jamais dire et faire diminuer cette
dette tout en sachant qu'il ya la
mauvaise dette celle qui sert à payer le
fonctionnement de l'état c'est-à-dire
sans gaz son électricité mais il ya la
bonne dette celle qui sert à investir et
à préparer le futur bon s'il faut
assainir les comptes publics où il faut
le faire pour redonner des marges de
manoeuvre mais en revanche il ne faut
pas non quand même au béret mettre en
péril la croissance
le développement la justice sociale et
donc sommes certains députés quelques
députés est de plus en plus nombreux
d'ailleurs au sein du parti série du
groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale à avoir quelques quelques
idées en ce sens qu'on vous ne sentez
pas aujourd'hui représentée par le
gouvernement vos idées les idées
socialistes ne sont pas représentés par
la politique menée par manuel valls que
non je ne serai pas aussi là aussi aussi
c'est vers quoi je ne serais pas aussi
sévère vous savez la vème république et
c'est une bonne chose
la vème république organise le primat la
primauté de l'exécutif sur le législatif
et l'exécutif et c'est une bonne chose
moi je suis pour la 5ème république vous
souvent rappelé la quatrième république
c'était le bavardage incessant parlement
des gouvernements qui durait trois mois
six mois à l'instabilité ça c'est pas
bien
l'exécutif aujourd'hui à tous les moyens
pour faire entendre sa voir tous les
moyens légaux l'exécutif n'est pas très
doué avec on voit même du côté des
nordiques ce n'est pas le cas non plus
voilà c'est le seul où je veux en venir
c'est que
si en plus on interdit aux députés en
plus de ce cadre légal on interdit aux
députés franchement d'apporter leur
contribution de dire des choses à
l'exécutif ça ne sert à rien d'avoir une
assemblée nationale honnêtement c'est
pas la peine d'avoir 577 députés et vous
avez le sentiment que ça sert à quelque
chose vous êtes entendu 5 avril 2014
c'est le premier courrier de l'appel des
sens adressée à manuel valls pour
obtenir ce nouveau contrat de majorité
et coopération plus efficace avec le
gouvernement vous êtes entendu vous avez
ce sentiment là ça sert à quelque chose
tout à fait il ya eu quand même je vais
dire des ouïes des concessions faites
par l'exécutif en particulier vous savez
sûr qu'on va dire le gel des pensions de
retraite quoi et le seuil 1 qui a été
qui a été sa place à l'appel des sens
tout à fait je crois donc c'est un on va
dire c'est un dialogue qui s'est
installée au constructif qui s'est
installée qui s'est instauré entre
l'exécutif et les députés socialistes ce
matin nous étions en réunion du groupe
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale et
c'est comme ça que les choses doivent se
passer
une fois de plus nous ne sommes pas des
selon la formule consacrée des députés
godillots voilà nous avons des choses à
dire et nous lisons dans une loyauté à
l'exécutif au gouvernement et au
président de la république
qui qui nous écoutent 9 juin ce
collectif l'appel des 100 fait des
contre-propositions au dernier budget
prévu par le gouvernement avec un taux
de la csg sont les revenus cent
cinquante mille emplois et des cent
cinquante mille contrats en alternance
autre proposition de concentrer les
baisses d'impôts des entreprises sur
celles qui en ont réellement besoin ces
propositions seront reprises appliquée
oh oui tout à fait puisque vous savez
vous en avez eu l'assurance en tous les
cas il va y avoir des textes budgétaires
qui vont être débattues à l'assemblée
nationale au mois de juin c'est à dire
la loi de finances rectificative
collectif budgétaire
et également la loi de finances sur la
sécurité sociale rectificative bien
effectivement vous savez que l'exécutif
proposait un allègement pour les
entreprises de 41 milliards d'euros nous
nous pensons que c'est important de que
de simplifier le cadre législatif légale
pour les entreprises que de leur
permettre de se développer
quel certainement moins de cotisations
sociales mais on rééquilibre aussi par
une politique de la demande et on
souhaite que justement cette politique
de l'offre soit soit rééquilibré par
plus de justice sociale de l'argent mis
effectivement
pour le développement des emplois pour
une csg qui soit moins élevé pour les
classes moyennes et les classes
populaires pour l'investissement public
local également donc il ya toute une
déclinaison
si vous voulez on souhaite qu' il ya un
petit peu plus de 20 milliards de ses 41
milliards initialement prévus par
l'exécutif pour alléger les cotisations
des entreprises que 20 milliards 20
milliards pardon soit me soit soit mis
sur sur la demande pour une meilleure
justice sociale voilà et pour qu'on
n'oublie pas que vous savez un des
facteurs un des vecteurs de la
croissance et on souhaite que la
croissance redémarre on souhaite que
l'activité économique redémarre un des
vecteurs c'est quand même c'est quand
même l'emploi c'est quand même la
demande c'est quand même le pouvoir
d'achat et ça c'est très important donc
on souhaite à la fois faire cette
politique de l'offre que veut le
gouvernement mais pas uniquement avec
une politique de notre gouvernement le
parti socialiste plus globalement va pas
dans le mur aujourd'hui entre les échec
aux européennes aux municipales la
contestation dans la rue à la csn cf du
côté des enseignants sur la réforme des
rythmes scolaires la réforme taubira
aussi est ce que le parti socialiste ne
mène pas la bonne politique aujourd'hui
ne répondent pas aux attentes non mais
c'est difficile de toute façon c'est
difficile effectivement c'est pour ça
que nous nous privilégions cette
politique que l'on espère de de la
justice sociale quand on souhaite
rééquilibrer
la politique du gouvernement et manuel
valls un discours très ferme il ne veut
pas lâcher du lest que ce soit sur la
sncf par exemple oui sur les rythmes
scolaires benoît hamon pour remplacer à
l'assemblée nationale qui a été élu
député maintient cette réforme des
rythmes scolaires et à la vie des
quelques fois de son sens d'ailleurs
puisqu'on voit dans certaines communes
puisque les communes sont libres
d'organiser leur temps libre ça tourne
un peu la garderie quelquefois et le
gouvernement soit rien faire dit oui
mais vous savez comment dire on est dans
une situation de crise difficile
tout le monde ne voit pas ce qu'est
l'intérêt général par exemple sur les
rythmes scolaires vous m'en parlez moi
je le point de départ de cette réforme
des rythmes scolaires c'est quand même
l'intérêt de l'enfant c'est quoi
l'intérêt de l'enfant c'est un constat
partagé par tous les spécialistes les
experts les chronobiologistes
aujourd'hui en france la journée de
l'enfant est beaucoup plus chargé que
dans tous les autres pays de l'osce et
des biens et donc on dit il faudra qu'il
y ait une cinquième matinée pourquoi une
cinquième matinée parce que là aussi
tous les experts sont d'accord tous les
chronobiologistes sont d'accord pour
dire que c'est entre 9h et 11h le matin
que les enfants apprennent le mieux
voilà donc ensuite effectivement
viennent se greffer la bombe et
plusieurs discours quoi si vous voulez
un des gens qui sont d'accord pas
d'accord on voit bien que des
municipalités
mais comme par hasard beaucoup beaucoup
de municipalités et dans les yvelines
j'ai quelques exemples concrets dans
votre circonscription ont joué un jeu
politique là dessus des bougies parité
ump hauts comme ça a priori les
gouvernements devraient pas parce que la
réforme n'est pas forcément populaires
non plus on parle de l'éducation mais au
delà de au delà de ça la réforme taubira
la sncf le gouvernement fait ce qu'il
faut le gouvernement fait ce qu'il faut
le gouvernement le gouvernement se bat
pour trouver des solutions
vous savez sur la sncf par exemple on
pourra peut-être en parler mais
justement je vais vous interrompre mais
juste parce que j'aimerais écoutez la
réaction d'un représentant cgt de la
sncf qui est venu vous interpeller avec
certains de ses collègues et c'était
lundi est celle juin à votre permanence
à trappes on en voit les images
justement et on écoute cette réaction
recueillie après les changes avec vous
monsieur maladie qu'il n'est absolument
pas au courant du projet de loi pour le
moment ce qui est quand même inquiétant
puisqu'il va être étudié et débattu en
procédure accélérée
donc on est pour le moins surpris du
fait qu'il n'ait pas connaissance du
dossier d'autant plus que la ville de
trappes est une ville où le chemin de
fer avait quand même une importance
énorme puisque le développement de la
ville a beaucoup été flottant du chemin
de fer et que le déclin du chemin de fer
qui étaient principalement organisée par
les pouvoirs publics et la direction de
la sncf
créer des problèmes d'emploi notamment
sur le bassin de trappes crée des
problèmes de circulation de camions sur
la nationale 10 et tout ça c'est des
problèmes qu'on retrouve globalement sur
la ville de trappes un pas que de
trappes mais tous les alentours et
monsieur mal et semble complètement
ignorant de ce sujet là c'est pour le
moins surprenant je vous laisse répondre
vous connaissez ce dossier oui bien sûr
c'est pas ce qui semblait être voulu
vous savez présentant cgt et quel est
votre point de vue au delà de sa
renommée ou non mais mon point de vue
c'est d'abord fait je tiens à le dire
j'étais ça le diacre et midi en rendez
vous à mes permanences donc voilà
évidemment qu
trentaine de militants de la cgt qui
sont venus sans rendez vous et qui qui
sont venus dans la permanence pour
parler de ce
projet de loi que je connais bien mais
vous savez c'est difficile de dialoguer
avec trente militants cgt moi j'aime
bien discuter avec deux trois personnes
pour aller sur le fond on discutait avec
30 personnes c'est toujours toujours
compliqué de l'allant sur le fond
nouvelle date symbole de respect sur
cette réforme tout roule hier il faut la
fermer ou ne comprend pas la fin comment
vous dire d'abord dont je respecte les
syndicats et la cgt
organisations syndicales parmi les
autres qui quittent importante et on va
donc pris par le temps dès que je
respecte les autres bourses mais mais je
ne comprends pas la réaction là de ses
militants puisque le projet de loi a été
lorsqu'il a été élaboré il ya eu
vraiment une concertation étroite
étroite avec en particulier la cgt qui a
été à tous les stades de la confection
de ce projet de loi a été informé bien
ce projet de loi d'une certaine façon va
dans la direction de ce que souhaitait
la cgt c'est à dire une réunification
vous savez de la sève de rff et la sncf
il y aura trois établissements publics
industriels et commerciaux donc la femme
de tête et deux la sncf mobilité et
réseaux qui seront chapeautés par cette
cet établissement public il ne s'agit
pas de remettre en cause le statut des
cheminots donc on me parle dont ils ont
tort de faire grève oui non je ne dirais
pas qu'ils ont tort de faire grève parce
que la drève la grève est un droit
constitutionnel mais je les respecte
profondément cette semaine les usagers
commencent à en avoir marre aux oui tout
à fait il faut parler de ce qu'il ya
dans le projet de loi et ne pas être
dans dans des choses qui ne sont pas
dans le projet de loi merci jean
philippe meunier député ps des yvelines
prochain numéro du 7-8 politique le 1er
juillet cette édition les précédentes
sont à voir en replay sur notre site
internet très bonne soirée